Josh Allen I wouldn't say he has a  defensive like mindset but he has I'm  gonna run through you like a  [ __ ] mindset like he's not  scared of contact I would he prefer  contact I'm sure he wouldn't but he'd do  it Josh is probably one of my favorite  players in the league I met him at the  Super Bowl last year I almost feel like  he was my brother his energy is like  contagious he one of the guys bro can  you tell Josh to give me a jersey please  like I want to gain one like Josh you  out there if you're watching and  somebody clip this Josh send me a jersey  it'll be here this week I'm not even  playing like it's done Josh Allen Jersey  coming to the store by the end of the  week it's going up in my man cave he  might even make the bedroom wall like